for these Chinese tourists seeing the
Great Barrier Reef with their own eyes
is a dream come true some 2 million
visitors flocked to Australia's
northeast coast every year to marvel at
the underwater paradise but behind the
pretty pictures there's a sad story over
the past 30 years the reef has lost half
its coral and now the underwater marvel
faces a new threat just a few kilometres
away several large projects are planned
along the coast of Queensland state to
boost Australia's coal exports is there
still time to save the Great Barrier
Reef
the Great Barrier Reef is a study in
superlatives
it stretches 2300 kilometers making the
coral reef the planets largest living
organism a true natural wonder
it's also a paradise for divers
Tony Fontes who's from the US came to
Australia as a backpacker 30 years ago
he only intended to stay a few weeks and
earn a little money as a diving
instructor but he ended up staying one
day I'll see a green turtle which is
pretty amazing because they're
endangered in their own right but we do
see them regularly on the reef where
they're protected and then during whale
season to see a whale from above water
is amazing to see what underwater is a
once-in-a-lifetime event which I've
managed to do once and I'm waiting for
that next time so the beauty of the
Great Barrier Reef is you never know
what you're gonna see but you know
you're going to see something absolutely
amazing every time you give mint UNESCO
declared the Great Barrier Reef a World
Heritage Site in 1981 it's hard to
believe that these waters could one day
be home to a sludge dump which is what
the Australian government is planning
cherry muddle works as a campaigner for
the Australian Marine Conservation
Society she's showing us the Abbot Point
project just 40 kilometres from the
coral reefs the coal port on
Queensland's East Coast is at the center
of a bitter debate between Australia's
energy industry and environmental
activists our point will be the largest
coal port in the world on the doorstep
of the Great Barrier Reef it's a world
heritage area seventh wonder of the
world
and they're planning to dump 5 million
tons of spoil mods in the reefs waters
the controversial plan calls for a
massive expansion of Abbot Point sport
in order to accommodate bigger coal
freighters that would involve building
new terminals dredging the channels and
dumping millions of tons of sludge into
the sea anyway in the Great Barrier Reef
it's a World Heritage icon not
the latest science shows that when you
dump dredge it doesn't just sit there it
spreads and it can spread up to 80
kilometers manikins settle and spa the
corals the seagrass diving instructor
tony Fontes fears the plans could spell
the end of the Great Barrier Reef over
the past three decades he's witnessed
the gradual erosion of the coral which
form an extremely delicate ecosystem
climate change tropical storms and
fertilizers used in agriculture have
already taken a heavy toll on the coral
but the booming coal industry and plans
to expand harbors are adding to the
perils UNESCO is threatening to revoke
the Great Barrier Reef's special
designation that would be the biggest
embarrassment I can imagine for a
government to lose the listing world
heritage area while you're on watch
can't be anything more embarrassing but
also be a real blow to the tourism
industry because having something as a
world heritage area it's very special
it's a responsibility we have to the
world to protect the world heritage
values the Great Barrier Reef the
government has already approved the
Abbot Point expansion plan the
Townsville based agency in charge of the
coral reefs Protection had the final say
we had to wait several weeks before our
request for an interview was granted the
meeting place the Great Barrier Reef
Aquarium promising a pretty backdrop at
least Russell Reichert is Australia's
top coral reef protection official he
insists that the port expansion plans
are completely safe
he's also brushed aside concerns raised
within his department we think that by
staying within the existing ports the
the damage if they would there will be
no unacceptable changes to the system
it's a load by the big scale it's a low
impact operation to maintain those ports
and it will be a very long distance from
existing major coral reef systems it's a
very big system but there are fears that
even slight tinkering with the eco
system could have drastic consequences
many people's livelihoods depend on the
Great Barrier Reef not suffering any
further devastation Tony Brown takes
tourists on cruises to the coral
paradise point project is only 40
kilometers away from the route he takes
sustainable industry we are here we want
this this area to be pristine for future
generations for everyone to enjoy I
can't understand how you could be
looking at a non sustainable industry
such as coal there's so much issues
about the way Cole's going in its price
to go out there and do these ports when
there are better options than sea
dumping I mean we're not asking if it's
a modest request do not see dumped in
the marine park don't take the risk Tony
Brown is convinced the government will
do whatever it takes to help the coal
industry so he's decided to take up the
fight from a different angle his aim is
to persuade major banks not to help
finance the multi-billion dollar harbor
projects
his biggest success so far winning over
deutsche bank so we thought why don't we
go speak to the financial institutions
these guys need money there they don't
have a bucket full of money they need to
borrow suspected which a bank explained
our situation and literally let's be
honest if they can put a condition on
there that the best practices is the
only way they're going to give a
condition to financing Abbott points
expansion then that seems the the only
way so far the coal industry isn't
worried Australia is the world's biggest
coal exporter and plans call for
doubling foreign deliveries in the
coming years
the industry is hoping to dig new mines
in Queensland's interior and expand at
least five ports on the coast
Michael Roche is an energy industry
lobbyist and he predicts a golden future
for coal well it's such an important
part of the economy and we know that
coal demand globally is going to keep
growing particularly in Asia not just
China but also India and Southeast Asia
they're strong markets 10,000 colleges
but environmentalists fear coal will be
the final straw for the Great Barrier
Reef Greenpeace has launched online ads
like this one to heighten awareness
about the coal projects activists claim
marine life including dolphins will
suffer if the plan goes ahead but
lobbyists say the environmentalists
campaign is misguided I know that the
Great Barrier Reef has some challenges
but they know those challenges don't
come from port development and dredging
that won't stop the social media
campaigns by the activists they are very
keen to shut down the coal industry
while the coal industry repeats its
claim that port expansion and dredging
pose no risks some people say they have
evidence to the contrary crews began
expanding the port in Gladstone three
years ago people here say they've
already been affected by the
consequences
mark macmillan is a third-generation
fisherman and is taking us out to see
the new terminal in order to make the
harbor navigable for bigger freighters
millions of tons of silt were dredged
from Gladstone and dumped out at sea
things weren't too bad for us until the
dredging started them you know it's you
almost just flick a switch once once the
full-on dredging started we were
catching some mackerel in the harbor
further down the harbor
they just disappeared overnight from 200
kilos a night to zero on land one of the
world's largest liquid gas export
terminals is taking shape mark macmillan
used to throw his nets where the gas
freighters will soon be docking you've
only got to look at it and any person
that can tie their own shoelaces can
can't tell me that this does not have
any effect on the environment it's look
at it
most people involved in the fishing
industry have given up that are seeking
compensation from the courts but mark
macmillan wants to continue fishing even
though much of his catch is unfit for
sale he shows us salmon he caught a few
weeks ago and froze as evidence the fish
have red eyes and show signs of bleeding
Macmillan suspects that pollution from
the harbor floor made the fish sick so
far the Port Authority denies any
responsibility I'm 100% sure it's got to
do with the dredging I'm positive
I'll add what else can it be there is no
other no other excuse for it because
we've never seen it before
but porn expansion is going ahead in
spite of those concerns environmental
activist cherry muddle fears more
situations like the one in Gladstone if
elected officials don't change their
thinking it's extremely frustrating if
you look at Gladstone
we still have many questions unanswered
it was an environmental disaster yeah
the Australian Government is fast
tracking massive industrialization on
the reef and they're approving millions
and tons of dredging and dumping in the
reef Globetrotters hoping to experience
the Great Barrier Reef and all its
beauty would be well advised to hurry up
activists fear the Kuril won't survive
the fight against the coal industry
you